we're here with Harold Hamm the CEO
chairman founder of Continental
resources in Oklahoma City this is a
pretty auspicious occasion because
Harold has a book coming out your your
Memoirs your autobiography your record
of the last
how many years now 50 years of running
this company well about 56. 56. okay so
um the book is coming out what was the
process like what do you feel like
you've accomplished with this book
well it was a story that had to be told
and had to be told for a whole lot of
reasons
and you know I deserve to be told
and it was the story of the American
Energy Renaissance
and how it came about
there's been a lot of disparaging things
that said about our industry and untrue
things
and so it those had to be talked talked
over and
and and debated somewhat and and get to
the real truth of the matter it all
happened because of one thing and that
was horizontal drilling right our
ability to go in and uh turn uh 90
degrees and go one to two miles and
stimulate a section of Rock
that opened up all the the tight
reservoirs in America so without these
advances in horizontal drilling and and
fracking I know you're not a fan of that
term but that's how people people know
it
um we wouldn't have had the tremendous
growth in oil and gas production in this
country it just wouldn't have happened
right so so your book tells the tale of
this whole fracking Revolution but more
importantly as far as I'm concerned it
you talk about your role in it you were
there at the very earliest stages you
helped open up the the Bakken in North
Dakota to Drilling and now you're in the
Permian and in Oklahoma as well what was
one point in writing that book what's a
favorite scene what was something that
that really sticks with you that that
for many years you were like gosh I got
to get that in the book
well there was a whole lot of those aha
moments if you will but you know the
just the ability to tap a reservoir that
had not ever produced vertically yeah
and bring it into production uh and and
do it and we're talking
like Cedar Hills Reservoir
uh
you know in drilling that I mean these
Wells were never stimulated just the
well bore uh itself
was enough to bring the production on so
yeah that's uh there was just a whole
lot of moments but you know this was
back when nobody was doing this so it
was uh you know two only two companies
worked in the entire field of Cedar Hill
to ever drill Wells
and they were all horizontal Wells
and you know this was 1995 before people
were thinking about this at all
now you you were able to write this book
after you took Continental resources
private last year we haven't had a
chance to talk a lot since then how does
it feel now to have a private company
for all these you know what was it 30
years about you were public you had to
be accustomed to that quarterly cycle of
dealing with analysts and investors now
that's all gone how how does that feel
and what kind of Burden has that lifted
off your shoulders well certainly it
felt like 30 years Chris but it was only
15.
2007 to 2000 uh uh 22. and you always
had a controlling stake in the company
for sure but now tell me how much more
time you have to to work yeah it's
tremendous uh you know it uh back when
we took it the company public and we
didn't sell but 15 of it at that time
and and we had a need to do that to
develop the Bakken uh which we were in
the process of
so we hadn't need to do it and and you
know the market would pay you to be be
public
that kind of ceased to be the case after
colon okay uh came about and uh so it
wasn't uh something that we need to do
any longer so we brought back that 15 16
percent
and I took the company private
and it it changed everything instead of
thinking about quarterly the next
quarterly call
to inform the public of what the company
was doing we're thinking about the next
quarter in the next 25 years okay so it
changed a whole lot but the next Century
as well yeah
and so and we need to look that far
ahead in this business I really do
the time wise you ask about that that's
a big big factor uh my CEO and I
we estimate about 20 Savings in time 20
savings 20 so it's big and it it not
just from the top levels uh chairman of
the board CEO
but it's all the way down through the
company would you suggest that other oil
companies do the same thing if they're
if they have a strong enough balance
sheet that they don't need to rely on
the public markets well certainly they
would uh right now but there's very few
uh that financially able to do that
right and we were fortunate now you
mentioned your CEO at Doug Lawler you
hired him from Chesapeake of course
um congratulations it sounds like you've
found someone that you're happy with and
that you can trust running your company
yes uh you know Doug and I uh he's a
tremendous person uh had a background at
Anadarko later Chesapeake and actually
he had left Chesapeake so he wasn't
there at the time I hired him but uh
he's a tremendous tremendous asset
leader a great leader
he works with our teams they love him
and respect him and he's just a great
great person it's a great division you
don't need to come into the office
anymore you can just check out huh well
you know it's almost that easy uh and I
could I could be away a lot more but
have a lot of special projects that
we're working and uh working with the
you know completionist book was one of
those uh
uh projects and I'm glad to you know
have that finished
there are several others uh projects
working with the ham Institute and
you know the summit that we are going to
do this coming fall
September 25th
so it's uh it's quite significant some
of the things we're doing that's good
um on the on the oil and gas side can
you tell me about any um your most
exciting well that you guys have drilled
recently or which part of the country
that you're you're most excited about is
is your Permian acquisition is that
where you're spending more time and
effort well we've always been someone
that's generated our ideas and building
Concepts and geologic Concepts and
internally internally and inside the
company and certainly we've always done
that uh the most recent
addition to that has been the Permian
and we were actually have had a geologic
uh concept that that put us in the
Permian and we released a a lot of land
prior to the acquisition of the the
properties that we bought from Pioneer
okay but that was a a good acquisition a
good time
to do that
and a very good property
and we're glad we did that so in
addition to
the properties that we owned out there
and we've added to that position
considerably
um
so in
in the past you had to tell the street
you had to tell analysts about your most
exciting material
changes that were happening in the
country and in the company is there
anything that you can share with me now
that that you know the world might not
know about that that is exciting along
those lines well there's a there's
probably a lot that the world doesn't
know about uh
you know
is because we have we haven't had to
report
anything uh to the street other than
their 10ks and so what's been going on
under under the radar yes you see uh we
we've we've grown production uh somewhat
uh you know not tremendously uh but
we've had uh nice uh steady growth
consistent growth
uh over the past several months
that's when we took the company private
September November of 2022
and uh
the addition of the additional work that
we're doing in The Firm in uh most of
that is new and so
it's a it's exciting uh
and uh we're glad to be there doing what
we're doing and and having having fun uh
not only there but with the other
properties
the Powder River Basin is one that we're
active in very active in and that's a
new basis to us in Wyoming in Wyoming uh
we have a considerable amount of acreage
one of the largest acreage holders
I've been in the Powder River
and uh so
it's that that's new and exciting as
well well when when you went private um
the word in the industry was oh Harold's
G's just going to drill baby drill now
just wait now that he's Unleashed he's
going to drill like crazy you know I've
known you for a while and I feel like
that's probably not what you would do
because you've always been very careful
to you know make sure you don't lose
your shirt or that anything bad happens
to your company but but tell me do you
feel Unleashed at all as a result of
this are you perhaps truly more than you
otherwise would have well there's a lot
of freedom to do that uh if you wanted
to and but your our number one priority
was reclaimant of debt that we took on
when we bought out the public sector
and so that's their number one priority
and and we the companies use a lot of
discipline and uh and soaring up its
balance sheet and doing all those things
necessary to you know be a good Stable
Company yeah uh so you know we we
haven't just that we I don't think we've
had any rig count really uh uh how many
are you out
yeah we've been at about 26 and I think
we're down
maybe the 23 24 to the point so I
haven't looked at everyone else's
numbers but that may be one of the most
active rig counts of any company in
America right now we've always been one
of the more active players in the in the
US I say always for a lot of years
there's a lot of years so you know
that's nothing new
but our actual root count since we 've
gone private uh the count is down from
where it was I think our efficiencies
are up a little bit
and so in fact I know they are
so we're doing more with fewer rigs
that's great when I was reading your
your book The the early version that I
was given
um I found that
I know that you you're not really an
effusive sharer of your personal
you know emotions and stuff
um and I was kind of surprised though
that there wasn't more in your book
about
yourself
and and your journey you had you have so
much in there on policy and what needs
to happen with American Oil and Gas
policy and also talking about the
industry over the past 15 20 30 years
but I wanted to ask you
why not more from the heart from Harold
well I've never been one to talk a lot
about myself okay so it's difficult for
me
and I don't have anything to hide I just
uh
you know I'm not I don't have a lot of
braggadacio okay
okay I guess
um as well look at it so
and there's a lot more important things
to be talking about
you know energy Independence uh our
quest for it right uh what that means
for America what it means for the world
and what it means in terms of World
Peace
and so all that is more important than
Harold Ham's personal story all of it is
more important uh the youngest of 13
children growing up Barefoot picking
cotton yeah I mean but you mentioned
that of course but yeah and I hope
there's enough in there that would
inspired the Next Generation absolutely
the next Barefoot country kid that has a
great idea I hope we can go forward with
that and and be inspired to do so
well tell me how you feel about America
when it comes to
the entrepreneurial Spirit of this
country and the opportunities for you
know young entrepreneurial minded kids
to build their own company and and get
ahead
um
where do you think we are
are we going in the right direction
wrong direction what's how do you feel
these days you know there's a whole lot
more regulation today than there was 56
years ago when I started they won't even
lease you Federal lands now yeah yeah I
know that's that's ridiculous
uh yeah so it's a little harder than it
was when you started yeah it's a lot
more difficult uh I think but it can
still be done
uh you know with the
uh the same
determination grit and
uh everything that same thing you took
when I started getting started
but uh it's uh it can still be done okay
so what's your advice to kids today who
are trying to make it in maybe not just
the oil industry any any field that
requires that same sort of discipline uh
takes a lot of focus yeah uh
determination
uh you know the Integrity uh
[Music]
uh you know being able to work hard yeah
work ethic is a big part of that
you know just staying with it yeah and
it's more than just the amount of hours
that you put in it's you got to work
smart
ours uh you know the ten thousand hours
I believe in that do you believe in that
I really do yeah put time in
uh you know there's
to get good at what you do and you know
I it did for me it took ten thousand
hours for me to be a good oil finder
and I think it will for the next guy
well you're probably going on 100 000
hours now so
it's been quite a quite a career
um so of course you've appeared on the
Forbes 400 list for many years now
um you fell in valuation recently after
you took the company private because
once you were private we have to take
all of the the debt load and deduct that
from the the equity valuation of the
company is that something that even
matters to you or registers to you that
you know according to stupid Forbes
Magazine I'm worth a few billion less
after I take my company private
um and and how do you how do you look at
that how do you think of your wealth and
and wealth in general
yeah I never did uh look at that very
much uh it that that wasn't uh
uh what it went into business for uh you
have to make money stay in business sure
don't get me wrong
and uh you'll go broke without it but uh
so that's that's part but
I never did uh
is more about the process having fun
yeah uh and
uh doing something that was important
something that was bigger than me uh
perhaps that would change the world as
horizontal drilling has
uh something very meaningful
so that that has been meant a great deal
perhaps more than
you know the final count really so it
was never about
you know a chip on the shoulder showing
that I've I got more a beer pile of
dollars than you guys that never really
drove you in in your career no it it was
always the the belief that if he did
everything right that was going to
that's going to be there yeah and it's
they tend to work out for us good
what's most exciting for you for the
rest of 2023 and into 2024 what are you
going to be focusing
most your time on in terms of you know
geology or operations or maybe it's
philanthropy what what are you really
engaged in these days well I think uh
keeping uh Continental on uh the path uh
to chairman of the board uh the path of
success and and uh and growth and and
all the things that you know it stood
for and uh you know all of our
hard-working people uh
make sure that uh you know we live up to
what they need and provide everything
that they need
that's a big part of it uh
y'all mentioned the ham Institute of
American Energy
uh you know the role that that can play
in the future
and has played already so this is a
think tank that you've created
it's more than a think tank it it does a
whole lot of things research and
uh and you name it but
the the main thing is getting all these
young people back involved in Industry
yeah uh through the various universities
that we're associated with
so that's that's a big part of it for
people who have not been paying close
attention to the Shale revolution in
America over the last 15 years uh it
really has not been possible without
technological innovations horizontal
drilling hydraulic fracturing these are
things that are common in the industry
now but when you started they weren't so
explain to us in in your own way what
makes these Innovations so vital and
responsible for the energy Revolution
that we're still in a part of horizontal
drilling coming about the the nation
production both for oil and gas was in
what we call terminal decline everybody
thought it was just going to be produced
out terminally through the 1990s it was
just falling and falling yeah and even
from the about mid 80s
so earlier than that and is terminal
decline began in the 80s late 70s and
it was going to be produced out and gone
yes and so we started early on with
horizontal drilling basically in the
late 80s a lot of people didn't know
what's going on
but it came on so quickly with some
really big things we did
uh Cedar Hill is a good example of 250
million Barrel field
our continental and Burdick is only
companies that ever drill welds in that
field and they were all horizontal they
wouldn't produce vertically and in the
past when the industry started you would
drill vertically to get the oil but that
wasn't working in Cedar Hills it did not
work so once you figured out how to go
horizontal then then suddenly these
welds would come on seven to nine
hundred barrels a day so it was it's a
game changer and the light bulb went off
and and and it went on offer a lot of
people suddenly
uh that happened so we we create
went on to create several big plays one
of which was a Bakken that Conan led
charge on uh
and other players for instance became
Pauper pretty quickly using his
technology
uh the Barnett big gaspai and suddenly
we had some people that wanted quickly
to disparage this industry and so they
went about it with a lot of money a lot
of resources and
we say they disparaged it by the
terminology
they they started calling it fracking
and and the f word became prominent they
called us frackers
meaning that and other bad things
and there was a whole lot of money that
was spent
some films made
that basically disparaged the industry
and particularly everybody thought if
they weren't knowledgeable that it was
just Innovation on fracking right well
wasn't his Innovation around the
horizontal drilling yes laying out
horizontal laterals and multi-stage
completions and and stimulation red
Forest uh that created everything we did
suddenly production zoomed
reversed the terminal decline
but a lot of people thought they had to
stop that Russia got involved
uh spent about 500 million dollars on
propaganda in this country on
anti-fracking propaganda because Russia
didn't they they felt threatened you
know gas prom felt threatened by
America's new Shale gas yeah and and
basically that their worth
uh uh uh of all the reserves that they
had in Russia if this went around the
world untethered
that that value was going to go to
nothing and that's exactly what happened
because without the the fracking
Revolution
the United States would not be able to
export such massive quantities of
natural gas in the form of LNG now you
know and especially sending that to
Europe to make up for the Russian gas
that they're they're not getting right
now that's exactly right uh so you guys
helped save the world in effect
absolutely let's think about how cold it
would have been in Europe last winter
right without all the shipments about
the Americans right that saved them
do you think that people are slowly
coming around to appreciate that story
sure they are they are because there
haven't been in the past decade they're
warning that oh fracking is going to
destroy groundwater and cause this
problem in that problem but there
haven't been a lot of issues sure every
industry has its problems but there
hasn't been
widespread instances of drilling and
fracking related problems you know and
well no in fact the propaganda if you
remember Gasland yes that was out there
I mean it was there's another film just
uh you know full eyes
they were claiming that uh you know the
what we were doing uh with horizontal
drilling and blamed it all on fracking
and uh there again and said it was going
to include all the groundwater in
America
that hasn't happened
so um that's interesting so that that
movie was probably 12 or 13 years ago
now that you've done your autobiography
and your book
you're going to make a movie who's going
to play Harold ham in the movie version
of your life
gosh I don't know
definitely some somebody a lot better
looking eye let's call George Clooney
and see what we can do but it's a great
book and um it's great to see you again
so thanks a lot for your time you bet
thank you Chris